hi rich and adam this is adrian grove
from
london england and my question to you
both is about real conversation and
communication
as an actor for 25 years i've noticed
that during breaks in rehearsal or
on set whereas everyone would sit around
drink coffee eat and talk now they're
silence as people
sit by themselves checking the latest
social media feed or
how many likes they have
and on social events too conversation is
stilted as the the ping of notifications
draws people away
and you're left wondering why am i here
so
my question to you both is how do i stop
getting frustrated with
my friends and colleagues how do i
stop feeling like an out of touch
dinosaur at 52
and how do we as a society promote
real conversations that's a great
question
uh thank you for that yeah i think the
best way
to open up my response to that is to
hearken it back to that roomy quote
right yesterday i was clever so i wanted
to change the world today and why so i'm
changing myself
yeah we can we can
uh be upset that the world is the way
that it is
but it is the way that it is and
frustration over that will only result
in in your own personal suffering
over the whole thing um you're not going
to get
to change other people's behaviors all
you can do is change your own
so to the extent that you're dismayed by
the fact that everybody's
face planted in their phones the only
thing that you can do
is be the instigator of that change and
how it relates to your own personal
relationships right so be be the one who
goes up to your friend and says hey
let's go for a walk or why don't we go
on a hike or let's go on a bike ride or
let me meet you
for a socially distanced coffee or
whatever it is like just to make those
adjustments yourself and take
responsibility
so that your own life is
is you know infused with the personal
interactions that you're seeking and
perhaps missing right now
but to let go of how other people are
behaving and being upset about that
right yeah because that will just foment
your frustration
the second thing um that i would say is
that you want to be like eric clapton
and not like
the guy who's still hanging on to the
the uh heavy metal hair band that he was
in the 80s
let me explain what i mean by that is
is to the extent that you're 52 and
feeling like a dinosaur
embrace the fact that you're 52 right
yeah when we see
eric clapton show up later in his career
he's well appointed wearing an armani
suit looking very nice
still rocking it out but comfortable
with the fact that he's
growing older yeah and not trying to
hang on to
some you know 20-something version
of who you are with the receding
hairline but still you know trying to
look the part right right there's
something more dignified about
embracing the truth of where you're at
rather than
trying to pretend like you're you know
going to be a tick tock star
yeah you know what i mean just you're
saying bring a newspaper to the set
and when everyone's on the phone like
ripple it
fold it up yeah that that actually would
be cool
right that would be kind of funny a
little protest with the riffling of the
paper
yeah i mean i think the point that i'm
making is like you don't fee
don't don't put the pressure on yourself
that you have to keep pace with every
new
trend or iteration of of technology
that's happening
you want to be current so that you can
maintain your relationships
and have some sense of what's going on
like you don't want to be completely
checked out
yeah but at 52 you don't have to be
on top of all that stuff right no and
but you're also not a dinosaur just
because you're not addicted to your
phone
as a 54 year old i take personal offense
at that
um but i mean i think i think that
like it's cool to have standards that
you think
people should interact in a in a more
healthy kind of less tech connected way
i think that's
okay sure you know and and to to feel
that way and to model that behavior
it's cool like in a way it's like it's
cooler
to model the behavior right you don't
actually have to
um engage and try to change anybody but
to model it
especially on a set or something like
that i think that could actually work
very well
for you yeah be the one who sets the
tone for everybody else and
to your point about eroding attention
spans like i i don't know that that's
really true we like to throw that around
everyone nobody has any attention span
for anything anymore but
you know this podcast is a counterpoint
to that
to that idea and perhaps the eroded
attention span is more myth propagated
by
media outlets than truth itself i do
think people look at their phones to
fill space though
like you know what i mean like when
nothing else is going on for like
comfort like a binky
like you know that doesn't mean that
they're not capable of having a long
conversation with somebody
in an interesting way right so just
because someone's looking at your
their phone doesn't mean you can't say
excuse me and start a conversation right
they're waiting for you to model that
behavior they're waiting for you adrian
in all of your wise 52 years
eric clapton style yeah thanks for that
question man all right
[Music]
you